thank you so much for having me here
i was a grad student back in the day in
the audience like some of you so it's
really fun to be upfront
um
all right so i'm going to start with a
kind of high level call to action this
is sort of like a kind of inspirational
talk if you will and i give you like a
wild tour through a lot of the work we
do
but i wanted to read you a couple of
quotes from sort of pundits in academia
and also in industry
so here's tristan harris we're training
and conditioning
a whole new generation of people that
when we're uncomfortable or lonely or
uncertain or afraid we have a digital
pacifier for ourselves that's kind of
atrophying our own ability to deal with
that
and for those of you who don't know who
he is he used to be a design ethicist at
google and now he runs this place called
the center for humane technology
and that's actually a quote from the
movie the social dilemma which maybe
some of you seen on netflix which is
sort of a dystopian take on what social
media is doing
here's a couple of quotes from sherry
turkle she is an academic at mit
this is from recon reclaiming
conversation
intelligence once meant more than what
any artificial intelligence does
it used to include sensibility
sensitivity awareness discernment reason
acumen and wit
and then another quote from a different
book of hers alone together
these days
insecure in our relationships and
anxious about intimacy we look to
technology for ways to be in
relationships and protect ourselves from
them
at the same time
so
i want to be clear that i am not a
luddite okay i don't want us all to go
back to running through the fields and
talking with tin cans and you know i
know like i'm no longer a super young
person so i just want you to know this
critique is not coming from a kind of
luddite point of view
but i do think that technology has sort
of slid into this sinkhole
of sucking our individual attention into
screens and kind of proliferating these
opportunities for us to kind of fall
down these rabbit holes and sometimes
those rabbit holes lead to the illusion
that we're having rich meaningful
connection with each other when when we
climb up out of them we realize wow
there's something missing in this it's
not as rich as it could be i'm not even
sure what's wrong but
something's going on
and i care about this so i have worked
in industry i've worked in design firms
i worked at a startup at one point
and i'm in academia now and my
perspective on what we can do in the
academy is that we can take
the long view we can consciously choose
to chart a different course if we like
from situations we see unfolding in
technology
so uh there are other people here at
stanford who do that kind of thing one
person that comes to mind for me is
michael bernstein who's a faculty member
in this program
who is you know really taking sort of
society and ethics bull by the horns and
thinking about his own work in social
computing
so i think especially engineering
schools we exist at this really
interesting intersection between
practicality in the world of making
things that are going to go out and
affect potentially millions of people
but also doing basic research that can
subtly shift the course of where we all
go and i think it's important to reflect
on that
and think about what we can do what our
positionality is basically in affecting
the future of technology and that's
basically what this talk is about in
some sense
so of course there are a lot of
different ways to do that
so sometimes technologists also get
involved in policy and advising
however at least for me the primary
tools of my trade of influencing the
direction of where things go
are a combination of building
technological prototypes of possible
futures
and also distilling out lessons from
building those prototypes and testing
them out with real people
to create tools for thought for other
people not just in research
but also out in industry
now i use the p word i use the play word
i know christina's bought into that
i'm going to introduce some tools for
thought today and i include play in the
mix
and
i know that for some people i think this
country in particular still has this
kind of puritan
work ethic background and there's
sometimes a suspicion of games and play
is maybe like a waste of time
maybe something sidelined or smaller
than serious weighty problems of the
world and i hope part of what will
happen in this talk is you'll see how
play
has become an important through line for
me in understanding the future of where
technology could go in a different way
this is my lab group this is a failed
kayaking
expedition we took as a field trip uh
there's this place elkhorn slough which
is south of santa cruz it was so windy
that day that we basically paddled
around in the harbor and then they
brought us back because they were scared
to take us into the slough so that was
kind of funny
we build stuff now we don't build stuff
on the level of say sean fulmer where
we're like hardcore engineering new
ground up technologies what we do is we
take near-term stuff that's gotten
stable enough that we can hack together
interesting visions of how the future
might be that people can actually play
with
and we obviously we publish in places
that was a poster at kai
but we also
show things this is the exploratorium so
we demo our stuff at like science
museums i've shown stuff in art
exhibitions like we found that actually
getting things to a resolution that's
high enough for everyday public to
interact with teaches us additional
lessons
and you've already seen the books
um
i should say before i was at uc santa
cruz i was actually at nyu
where i had a joint position between
computer science and the game center so
i was actually in two totally different
schools at the university and that was
definitely very interesting
i mentioned already that i worked in
industry for a while it's been a while
since i did that but i have a feel for
how all that works
and i write these books
oh and acm has decided i'm a
distinguished scientist so that's that's
the one other little bit of street cred
okay
so let's begin with a tool that helped
me to think more creatively about how we
got where we are now
you all familiar with this image
it's a little optical illusion
what do we see
anybody can answer what do you see
you see a vase
okay that's like me we're gonna talk
more about that what's the other thing
you see
two faces
my core argument in my last several
years of work is we're too fixated on
the two faces
and we're not fixated enough on the
contours of the space between people
when we design our technology
so
i wrote this little paper i'm glad to
share with christina and she can
propagate it out there was this really
interesting symposium called halfway to
the future
where we read a bunch of core papers in
hci from early on and then we all
reflected on where we had gone
and i wrote this piece saying somewhere
we took this crazy detour and we got a
little lost
in highly individualistic technology
and you know
anybody know who donna haraway is
she's this like old school media
theorist like basically a goddess of uc
santa cruz she wrote this book called
the cyborg manifesto in which she did
these juxtapositions to help people
notice their blind spots and their
thinking
and i thought you know what what if i
juxtapose what if i start like trying to
tease apart what is this creepy thing i
think has been happening with technology
i was like
it's too isolating it's too
individualistic this is bugging me but
what if i flip that what if it's the
opposite so i'm gonna i'm gonna set up
this juxtaposition for you so
right now we have this value that the
device is there to support me at my
convenience and serve information
perfectly adapted to me
it's kind of like my perfect companion
right we just take that for granted
but what if devices were there to
support us to support the space between
us collectively
toward a shared experience what was that
what if that was the primary driving
value you took when you designed
something
also the device can ask for as much of
it my attention as it wants at any time
it can make me stare at it and touch it
and ignore others
it's like a horrible spoiled like pet or
something it's kind of awful if you
start thinking it that way but what if
devices were deeply sensitive to not
interrupting
and rather enhancing my experience with
other people around me and actually was
able to avoid those eruptions
what if their signaling and input
these devices didn't get in the way
maybe it even added something to my
social experience is that too much to
ask maybe it's not right
right now we have this thing like
devices are like tribbles they're just
they're just just more and more and more
and more of them and everybody buy more
buy more buy more so more devices is
better
everybody needs their own and each
person should have all the functionality
like nobody should
think of like old technology like an
apple press
or a cotton gin people like come from
miles to use this device
they would form relationships they would
learn about things they could help each
other with
what if sharing devices was fine and
maybe even to be desired
because it's powerful to have
interdependent and distinct and unique
things sometimes so what if we operated
with that assumption
and then the last one is we this is
especially most recently there's this
hidden assumption
it's always okay for my device to
collect data about me toward farming
aggregate patterns to sell better stuff
to me as an individual
or to other individuals like me wherever
they are at some future time
but what if we said no
our devices should only use data they
collect about us to improve our
co-present experience right here in the
here and now
right not to say to like rigorously
stick to these but to set up this
juxtaposition to help you see kind of
the way i was trying to explode out
this design space yeah how about
improving your experience in the future
that would be fine too i think but it's
sort of like
i so i person this is a sidebar but i
personally think a lot of what's messing
with human relations right now
is the weird um endless presence of
things people say if you think of
twitter
so
there's a way and i've and i saw this
great piece ezra klein interviewed this
woman who was very astute in her use of
different media forms
she said she would only have complex
arguments on podcasts
because it's a lot harder to strip out
and reflect words
you can do it but it takes more effort
and people are lazy so they'd rather
retweet a tweet
so it's a good question but i think it's
a subtle question right
so
all right
so
i'm going to show you two research
through lines to give you examples of
how taking those juxtapositions into
account
shapes the kind of work we do and how we
think about
what we're trying to do in the world and
kind of show you how that evolves and
ends up providing tools for thought as
well
and i should say right now
the approach we take in our lab i
already said we're tinkerers
we build things with other people's
stuff we take what is called a research
through design approach
so we believe very much in knowledge
being produced through bottom-up making
that we learn as we go but we also
believe in the importance of abstracting
knowledge that makes it easier to share
so a lot of times we end up with what is
called mid-range theory that we're
sharing in papers like strong concepts
or sometimes we show a portfolio of our
work and we do what's called an
annotated portfolio but
i just want you to understand the kind
of work we do all right
and then i want to say one more thing
about why play
so probably those of you who have taken
a games class
know about the magic circle that
huizinga talked about
which is that
when we engage in a place situation with
others
we agree to step a little bit outside of
ourselves and to accept a different
reality consensually and together for a
little bit
and i think this is a really nice way of
thinking about
shaping different socio-technical
configurations even if you're not
explicitly designing a game
and i think it's a very valuable place
to look for because when we design a new
social technology
we have to get people to to take it up
and we have to understand what it's like
when they take it up you know i think a
classic example would be google glass
they did this thing where they like you
had to like apply to get one and they
distributed them really broadly across
lots of random people all over they
didn't create little pockets of kind of
power
quirky users of glass to help them
understand bottom up what was going to
happen they weren't thinking of the
social space around the technology so i
think thinking about games and play
helps us
to design this whole nexus of things and
i have a paper about that from a couple
of years about at kai and all along i
will be sign posting papers
and i will share these slides so you can
always track them down later
okay so the first strand of work i'm
going to talk about is our social
wearables work
so when we got into this um you know i
don't mind fitbits this is just you know
being a little dramatic here but
most of the commercially successful
wearables were like oh i'm tracking all
this data about me how many steps have i
taken or how many steps have you taken
and like that's how we're engaging right
or nowadays like with the with apple
watch and other similar things it's like
you can pick up phone or text messages
right but it's sort of social media
stuff so we're like
what if
we played around with social wearables
and thought about these social values
like could we come up with a really
different design space
around this stuff
so as i said before i was at uc santa
cruz i was actually at nyu and one of my
part of my joint appointment was in the
game center and i had met people who
were into larp
larp stands for live action role play
who here does not know what larp is
okay a couple of people so
this is like it's not like theater
because there's no audience
it's like more like a game of d where
somebody's like the dungeon master
they're larp designers
and they facilitate a shared experience
and people come together they get a
character they're improvising but there
are also these plot points and these
kind of emotional buildups
so i knew about larp and i was really
fascinated by this community one of the
cool things about them is they're very
particular about how they use technology
so we actually did this paper
for ftg a few years ago like his
foundational work before we got into
this design phase
and one of the things about larp is they
will not use a technology that distracts
people
no phones no watches like
they will only use the technology and
here's some pictures from the survey we
did about different technology they will
custom build
really elaborate wonderful things but
they have to support the group
experience of being in this interesting
story world
so
we went through two cycles of co-design
with larp designers and then deploying
devices
in their larps and in doing that we got
a lot of rich information from them
about like
what affordances of technology work
socially like what do they signal to
other people how how do they work with a
person as they're very engaged in a
narrative situation
i'm going to show you a little video
about one of those pieces this was the
second in the cycle
this was so when i actually when i first
moved to uc santa cruz i was like i saw
the campus i don't know if you've seen
it
it's like redwood trees and huge meadows
and i had this fantasy of people running
around with technology in the woods i
was like
i'm gonna like make a larp thing here
you know it's just like one of those
first thoughts as a researcher so i was
like yes
so we found this group
event horizon
and they actually ran larps not on our
campus but they ran larps in the marin
headlands okay they like had this cool
facility these multi-day larps
one problem is they didn't have any
network access so that made co-design
interesting but they were like a perfect
test case for playing around with what
could a social wearable be
if it was fitted into the story world
and it was doing something for not just
the one person but the whole group so we
worked with them to co-design this
wearable and then we deployed it in this
larp
and so i'll play this video that my
student made about it
[Music]
in 2018 we co-designed a social wearable
with a team of larp designers
the device affords a variety of
interactions
for example expressive ones
you can change the color displayed
[Music]
or create brightness patterns
[Music]
the device also affords competitive
behaviors
you can stun people
obviously when people can put you into a
state of overload by entering a code on
your back
in the game narrative when you are
overloaded you are limited in motion and
action
in fact the device makes you vulnerable
and it gets into overload automatically
every now and then
and since the wearable makes you
vulnerable people can come and help you
they can pat your back to help your
overload go by faster
or enter another code on your back to
remove it instantly
they can also enter a very special code
that will make you immune to overloads
altogether
a wearable affords a variety of
interactions both expressive competitive
and friendly ones
we deployed 15 copies of the wearable in
four weekend life event
109 people participated
we collected data by enacting researcher
characters in the game
and we found something very interesting
people were very excited about the
vulnerability afforded by the web
it encouraged people to care for one
another
it made new opportunities for social
interactions
that made us think
what if we design technology that makes
us vulnerable
we feel we just scratched the surface of
a really exciting opportunity and we
can't wait to continue exploring it
so contrast that with the fitbit
right
only okay so there's three classes of of
people in this larp the people who got
these wearables were called augments and
they were not cyborgs they were not
humans but they were augmented humans
okay
what was interesting is there was an
economy in the game and there was
supposed to be these um like wearable
technicians you'd have to pay them to
get you out of overload
no money changed hands
people loved helping the person in the
overload nobody stunned anybody else
nobody did anything sneaky the thing
they loved about this device
was when someone overloaded and they
could go help them it became this like
centerpiece of the interactions between
people and like to me that puts a very
different data point into the space of
what we could be doing with technology
that's worn on the body
now
vulnerability obviously comes with risk
larpers have this wonderful thing they
do first of all they allow people to set
boundaries when they come into a larp i
could be touched or i could not be
touched so they have really
elaborate safety protocols for people
and also
they always have a debrief together
where they all talk about how it went
and any of what they call bleed where
there were strong emotions that came up
so obviously you don't get off the hook
for developing this whole
socio-technical apparatus around making
people vulnerable
but we're brave and intrepid technology
designers we shouldn't shy away from
that right
like to me this says there's a really
interesting direction to go in um
so oops so you let me just hey stop that
google slides oh i went one too far hang
on
okay so you might be like yeah those
larpers they'll do that nobody else is
gonna do that so we started playing
around with uh how we could pull this
out of the larp situation
and my same student came up with this
this is a swedish word actually and it
should have a little circle over the o i
could not figure out how to get that
character i'm very sorry if anyone here
is swedish
lagom is this concept of everybody being
kind of equal and imbalanced
so we had actually a postdoc she's
actually from spain but she had gotten
her phd in sweden so that's how we named
it lago but anyway
so they created this so this is like it
looks like the clown flower that shoots
water out you know on a clown costume
except for that's a gooseneck mic
and it's it's a little processor
it's
i think it's an adafruit component
anyway we've switched so much i can't
remember which one it is but anyway
so it has simple haptic vibratory motor
and it also has little leds that can
light up
so this is a consensual
conversational balance tool
and the back story is these little
flowers they need nourishment of human
voice but they need it in moderation you
know you can kill a plant with too much
water or not enough water
so everybody turns them on at once and
then
as you're speaking it's keeping track of
how much you speak
if you don't speak at all it'll start to
give you a little general vibration or
if you speak for a really long time it
might also do that and then when
everybody's decided they're stopped
talking they can all push another button
at once and they all see what proportion
of the conversation they took up
so this is an attempt to kind of offer
people like consensual
visualization that combines like
personal signaling but also mutually
visible signaling to explore whether a
wearable uh could work in this way for
people now obviously there are lots of
little details to work out about this
if somebody's like me i'm blathering but
i'm like supposed to blather for you so
it would be really out of bounds so you
know there's a lot of nuances to work on
with something like this
interestingly people who didn't speak up
a lot kind of like this they liked
getting a little gentle silent haptic
vibration that nobody else saw
hey you could actually speak up so that
was kind of an interesting finding this
is this was just like a late-breaking
work so we didn't do a big big study
about this
more recently
the same student did this really
interesting project she actually had
high school interns in our lab for the
summer
and um they were playing around with
these little lightweight processors and
like ah you know like
we're all sitting in our dust too much
wouldn't it be cool similar to the
flowers who need conversational water
wouldn't it be cool if these little we
could make these little bugs that like
tie onto your shoe
they actually need proximity to each
other
so like if one of them gets a little bit
down you have to like get off your butt
and go find someone else who has one of
these little guys
right and
so interestingly so so this is this is
like a late breaking work type thing and
this this sort of shows you the dynamics
so you're just sitting there
periodically they go off basically and
they need to connect with others if they
don't get to connect they're kind of
going to get more frantic like oh please
please help me
but they do this only through vibration
and light so it's it's not super
intrusive
to you
so
in building these my student actually
this is one of those examples of
extracting out kind of mid-range theory
she was like
you know
we don't really think and this kind of
goes along with hci has where there's a
strand of hci that's trying to move away
from like
user-centered design to maybe like like
being center design like thinking about
not just people but like others and
maybe the ecosystem etc she was like
we don't really have working concepts in
hci for the interplay between the
technology and groups of people that
could kind of drive people to engage in
certain ways
and in this case the the shoe flies are
kind of like the bad cop because they
need a break and they need connection
and they drag you along
you know and so you find you're
interacting with other people more but
you don't feel embarrassed about it
because it's just like this this weird
thing and you're supposed to take care
of this this shoe fly she's like we
should really think about this idea of
synergistic social technologies like
what if part of designing the space
between people
was thinking about how technologies
could help us to balance and help us to
come into communication with one another
but in very general very respectful
maybe even playful ways right because
that device
obviously if you were to wear one it's
kind of a consensual okay i'll go along
with this you know i don't think these
types of things should be used um
draconian ly or in a required manner
things could get twisted in that way but
if people people always talk about how
they need to be reminded to take breaks
get out to lunch etc etc
if we were thoughtful about core
concepts that could help us give us
design tools to then build things that
people could build into their lives this
is the kind of thing that i'm talking
about
so
if we go back to this suprahuman idea of
like the space between then we could say
well
these devices this line of devices they
are there to support us
it's not about my little information
stockpile it's about i've decided i want
to have good interactions with other
people and i'm going to use this
technology to scaffold that in creative
ways
i would also argue that there's a
sensitivity there
some in some cases more than others but
at least the design awareness of the
cost of interruption and balancing
interruption with opportunity with
social opportunity
sharing devices i mean true colors get
set out a little bit maybe that one we
don't hit so much and then we really
have just used this localized data to
drive these interactions so we're not
using extractive data to make these
projects run
okay
so like that's like no screens at all
it's unfair to show this picture this is
actually a super cool project but i
freaking love this image
there's actually people on their own in
separate vr experiences and the the
technology is automatically directing
them not to run into each other
it's super cool but it's not but what i
think is funny about this is that
you know everybody's in their
hermetically sealed world and so
you might say to yourself oh wearables
you know that's an easy one because like
you took away the screen nobody can
focus on that of course they're focusing
on each other so now i'm going to show
you
diving all the way into the screen in
virtual reality which by the way
i was a total vr skeptic
i hated vr
and i was curmudgeonly about it and i
thought it was like kind of gross and
creepy
but as often happens a very talented and
bright young person came to me whose
name is joshua mcveigh schultz who
became my postdoc and is now a professor
at sf state and he's like
no you've got it all wrong like vr can
be really cool really amazing it just
needs good design attention he's like
this is a potentially transformative
meeting i'm like okay
i will work with you on this
so we set out to do a project together
which first started in getting him
funded so as a professor you're always
chasing funding so we got him a one-year
postdoc from mozilla
and then more recently we got national
science foundation money which i think
was helped by the fact that the pandemic
threw us all onto zoom right
so suddenly it became even more
desirable to figure out some other way
of gathering virtually than screens and
like looking like
whatever family feud brady bunch
whatever whatever metaphor you want to
use okay
so
i want to make a nod to the long history
around vr and even pre-vr
collaborative virtual environments like
people have been designing these spaces
for a long time
weirdly often extremely badly so i was
meeting with somebody before this talk
and they were asking me like
how did you like get into games and then
how did you why are you doing the stuff
you're doing now after games and part of
my motivation was
like early collaborative virtual
environments it was kind of like
floating corpses
there'd be like these like weird
floating corpses and they'd have no
facial expression and like they'd just
show up at coordinates and like you
couldn't even find your way it was so
bizarre but you know who was doing
immersive multi-person online worlds
really well games
they actually figured out a lot of
really interesting things about that so
however it's good to learn from all this
early work and these guys had really
astute things to say
so first we did our homework of learning
what came before us
and then we said hey
there's this nascent space
tons of interesting um new apps and this
was a few years ago now we're like like
artsy spaces like any land and then like
facebook spaces at that time like
lots of different players were starting
to get into trying to support social vr
so we're like
let's actually interview designers and
developers who are working in that world
and let's ask them
what do you do to make a space friendly
to make a space supportive for people
um
so we did this interviews with experts
project and there were actually two
papers that came out of this one kind of
the general ideas and the one my student
anja was really focusing in on avatars
and how we think about avatars
so
there were a lot of things we learned
this is kind of one of those smorgasbord
talks and i want to leave time for q a
so i'm not going to like get hardcore
into all of it i'll give you just a
couple of examples so one thing we
learned is
people tout full embodiment in vr but we
all know that's not true
we're only now starting to get facial
tracking like there's a lot of social
signals that aren't in there
so there's a lot of really interesting
control schemas for how to reintroduce
things like emotional signaling so like
rec room had these little flicks of the
wrist that could make your face change
they were trying to make it as intuitive
as possible kind of like puppeting your
face
and then a lot of them were just using
emoji because emoji had already
propagated elsewhere
and so that created interesting effects
like this
this is actually from a reggie watts
live concert
so for those of you who actually
participate in stuff like twitch
streaming like any kind of live
streaming situation
people were already used to kind of
flinging emoji and so people fling emoji
and vr too and they have a lot of fun
with it
and then also when this gets back to the
sort of old school virtual environments
research uh like
obviously it makes sense a lot of things
from real life we drag into vr spaces
and we set our expectations are set that
way
so the rec room people talked about how
when they first started rec room they
needed to have a place for people to
gather
and the avatars would just mill around
and it was chaos so they essentially
reinvented this
they were like hey wait
people have these social norms like if
you give them like an auditorium seating
and you give them a way to sit and
orient they'll just kind of do that
so they started to recreate these these
place and space metaphors in vr however
and this is this was kind of a clue to
where we decided we want to go
you see this like cat up in the top left
so
there was still the problem of like who
was speaking and in fact that's the
problem if you ever go to a conference
and they're using an audio system and
you have to step up to the mic if you if
it might gets passed around
you can't tell there's no spatialization
because because it's just coming out of
speakers so like let's make a giant cat
and it will be looking at the mic so
they pass around a virtual mic and you
can always tell who's speaking because
you just follow the gaze of the cat
like that is profound my friends that is
like
you can't i mean how much work would it
be to make a giant robotic cat in this
room it would be ridiculous we wouldn't
do it in vr it's so easy
there are just these very different
affordances for what can readily be done
and that little maneuver heightened the
social experience for people and made it
playful and kind of solved a problem
so that's just like a couple of little
insights from the interviews there's
lots of other stuff in the paper yeah
what what what do you feel about like um
people are doing socially inappropriate
things in vr nowadays yeah i think that
harassment and and weird social behavior
is a huge issue in fact
one of my students got harassed almost
immediately when we started doing our
because we the next thing is we did this
self-study of spaces and you have to
learn very quickly how to protect
yourself like people getting into your
in your body space or harass this is a
problem on all kind of anonymized
platforms not just vr
i think it's something that needs to be
designed around i think one of the
things that we saw i think it was rec
room
they if you put your hand up
you would just create the space around
yourself so one thing is you i think you
have to think about what do people
normally do when they protect themselves
and just like make that thing
work right away so it's going to work
for novice because that's one of the
biggest problems is like these harassers
camp on the novice spawning spots
our work took a turn where we decided to
focus on augmenting meetings between
people who already knew each other
because we saw that that was a little
bit less explored and kind of an
interesting terrain so i haven't done a
ton of work on
design mechanics but it's it's a super
important design space agree
okay oh yeah in the back
this is a later conversation really but
i um i also live in santa cruz and i go
to the lighthouse park yeah with my dog
regularly and the dynamics you keep
bringing up the shoe fly or you can cat
there's this kind of pet interface yes
being virtualized yes it's kind of
useful sometimes
you know my wife's the kind of person
i'm a dog person and she's like they
poop and they fight and yeah harass like
all these things and it requires more
vigilance especially if you like doing
dry land mushing yeah imagine like
complicated things with dogs yeah
but it is like a dog technology versus
cat technology
isolating with a comforting scent
versus going out and like banging into
things and it requires you to train it
where it doesn't work like it's
definitely wants to get it yes but if
you do it well yeah
what i love is to study the dynamics of
how people treat with doc like the dog
and the technology being trapped yes
everything you can think of
yeah well
this is actually
it came up in our musings so as we turn
to virtual meeting rooms
why are there no meandering pets in
meetings
why
because it's so great you take a break
you pet the pet you remark on the pet
doing weird stuff how many kitten
pictures circle around so i'm i'm with
you there
they're a proxy they're like a familiar
and
and it's a it's like a face saving
mechanism because you can always back
off from it but these are the subtleties
of human interaction that we should be
designing to support in my opinion
let's talk after the talk for sure
all right so okay so we narrowed it down
to meeting space like we're gonna we're
gonna like fix meetings they're not
gonna be in zoom anymore
these are the meeting spaces we decided
to investigate and first we went through
rather casually and then we kind of
in the interest of getting the work
published which we're still struggling
with we became more rigorous in our our
like process of checking out the space
went back through all of them we had a
checklist of things we did and a survey
we all filled out after
and we literally tried to have our stand
up okay we're just gonna like meet and
so we would have one person be the host
and they would have to make sure
everybody had the links they would set
up the sl the google doc if you could
put it in and we we like ate our own dog
food and just tried to see how it worked
um
again like not a ton of time i'll just
give you a couple of highlights and
hopefully this paper will see the light
of day in the next year and then i can
send it to christina
interesting thing that we noticed
was the business focused ones
they had a lot more of these like
kind of horrible pseudo business the
avatars
sometimes they had like zombie arms like
really like they were really focused on
business-ishness without a lot of depth
to what that might mean to individuals
it was kind of strange
whereas the more kind of consumery
places
such a plethora of beautiful and fast
like it could be a pizza
and we're like i want to be a pizza in a
faculty meeting i don't want to be
a zombie barbie like what so so like
that was interesting
and also meeting environments so a lot
of the startups and even the more
established companies
they're working really hard to create
these like
official businessy you know whiteboard
data markers like you know big
conference table kind of environment
but if you look at the more consumery
places where you can invite your friends
to a meeting
all kinds of crazy spaces and places
some have hybrid like glue vr actually
had this wonderful world so we were
having our meeting and then somebody
said oh there's this island world let's
go over there for a little while so went
over there and then there was this water
like oh can we get in the water or is it
just like you know like a sky box no it
was interactable water so we got in the
water
you could talk to each other under water
and the people above water could not
hear you so they're like
but you know what it was kind of bad for
a business meeting
so like you have to really think about
how distracting you want your
environment to be but anyway
i think one of the things we took away
from this is kind of the cat is not bad
and that we wanted to go more creative
in the kinds of things we were going to
implement
so i kind of pointed out this chasing
realism thing that's going on um and my
collaborator josh
really inspired by this very early paper
by holland stornetta that's like hey
we should be looking for new kinds of
communicative affordances rather than
imitating the mechanisms of face to face
so so we he actually led the writing of
this whole
alt khai
um weird the case for weird social in vr
that was at kai last year so highly
recommend you to read that
so with the remaining time i'm just
going to briefly show you
some of our prototypes some of this
started at usc when he was still a grad
student
so things like showing where gays was
going like actually visualizing gaze and
then we've been playing around we kind
of took the stuff from the wearables and
we've been playing around with
conversation balance
so um
we came up with this idea of these i
think there's a better picture in the
next no okay yeah this is a prototype
from usc
it was like what if like these colored
balls came out of your mouth when you
were talking and like everything would
pile up in this like sandbox right like
what might that be like
uh
and then one of my students kind of made
that a little bit more buttoned down i
was like well like uh it's hard to spawn
all those balls in a true network
situation like the latency goes up and
it's kind of a disaster so he came up
with this column that would slowly
disappear the balls over time
and actually did his master's thesis on
this
then
with this more recent nsf funded project
we retooled his design further
and now it is we poured it from unity to
mozilla and now it's these
what do you call that cylinders
that you're talking and a cylinder
stretches itself above you
and kind of pinches off when you stop
talking
and so this doesn't take nearly as much
uh like resource but you can actually
step back as an avatar and you can kind
of see the overall flow of a
conversation if you just look up into
the air it's kind of like little talk
balloons you know
so we've been running
kind of studies where we're comparing
well how does that affect people's
dynamics when they have this versus when
they don't
that's just one example we're doing a
lot of other kind of crazy more far out
stuff that isn't really ready to show
this is actually going to be demoed at
kai in the interactivity this year so if
you're there you can put on one of our
quest twos and you can try it out
all right oh and here's like an animated
gif
so we set up the desert survival problem
some of you may know what that is you
pretend you crashed in the desert there
are 12 items you have and then you have
to discuss
how to rank the items so we created this
little ranking tray so people work
together to like rank them from 1 to 12
and then we we look at
how does having this visualization
influence their balance of conversation
and all kinds of other variables
all right so circling back to the whole
super human thing
so you could think of vr as a collective
atmosphere
that was my student josh or my postdoc's
profound observation and this is true of
games collaborative games in general
they are often about the space between
people and so if you start to think that
way
then you can create all these strange
little
ephemeral or kind of playful affordances
that facilitate the coming together and
when people come into a shared space
they are in some sense stepping into the
magic circle and strange things may
happen in vr so it opens up a really
interesting terrain for being quite
creative about how to support things
like making sure your conversation is in
balance
all right
so
i am running out of time but
hopefully these prototypes and kind of
the thinking behind them shows you how
we are working on
reshaping social technology and by
showing you things that are distributed
on the body versus things where you're
full on immersed i want you to lift
those ideas off of specific technologies
and be thinking of them in a more
general fashion
i want to also add that i think it's
really important the interface with
industry so my student who did all the
social wearables work did a summer
internship at snap and she worked on uh
augmented reality lenses
that were highly social and like
intergenerational and super playful and
there's actually a paper at cscw about
that um and then i didn't even get into
our human food interaction stuff so we
actually got money from google's
well-being team to like unpack family
meal time and like how could tech not be
distracting so they're taking the bull
by the horns so
i'm not like a a critical theorist
i actually want to shift where we're
going with everyday
practice um
that
oh and
i i had friends who were in this when i
was in grad school here this is like
this cardboard bicycle exercise it's
like a hardcore engineering class but
like you build this crazy thing and then
you have to actually ride these bikes
like
i just think play is so integral to us
solving this problem but it's also
integral to the process
that we should have as technologists we
shouldn't be afraid to play and to think
about the texture of experience
including playfulness and getting
ourselves out of this kind of like
hole we've gotten into i just think it's
a temporary hole we have to dig
ourselves out of the hole and get
somewhere else
so
let's make tag for the space between us
and with that i'm happy to take
questions
[Applause]
yeah hi uh thank you for speaking um i
guess my question is with the decline of
like social interaction opportunity in
society yeah um how do you feel about
kind of like the consequent rise in like
virtual companions like that are 100
like artificial like whether that be
like romantic partners or pets or
friends yeah yeah so actually so in in
this book
i wrote a little bit about that with
japanese dating simulators
and i think
gosh i love science fiction
like i love philip k dick
he reflects on this
i think technology and media
they can help us more deeply understand
ourselves they could be a portal to
awareness
but i also think that machines
including machines imbued with machine
learning
they're not
like the fellow in the back was talking
about pets right
when you build a robotic pet you kind of
dumb down the model of petnus
you take away a lot of the friction and
resistance and individuality of the pet
the things that are pain in the neck but
that perversely make us care more
so i question the seamlessness of those
interactions i think if you were to look
at my juxtaposition of individualistic
versus collective technology
by taking away the friction the effort
the kind of surprising sort of
connection out of care that happens
between actual like biological beings
doesn't have to be human and human right
i think that you take something
essential out of it like if you look at
people who retire for example like older
humans
if they're not
taking care of things if they don't have
a role
that provides them with some friction
often they don't do as well so i think
that's a problem point i mean can you
solve that i don't know but that's a
place where i'm a little skeptical yeah
yeah
so i have a question about
your work in vr and meetings
i used mozilla hubs for meetings before
one of the issues we had was that you
know the lack of body language the lack
of ability to facial expression yes um
you showed kind of some approaches
people are taking with emojis and things
but that's not really real time yeah
have you done any like work
well we're super close to having facial
expression
like one of the students josh is working
with there's some actually i think it's
openly available thing he's he's porting
into hubs right now
so i actually think the industry is
about to solve that problem
and i think facial expression is a weird
one because it's a combination of
involuntary and voluntary signaling so
things like emojis can work with the
voluntary side but that's the
involuntary side now however why we're
not using neck movement more is beyond
me like disney there's this great book
the illusion of life by some disney
animators and they talk about how the
neck
is the essential place in animation and
we have the degrees of freedom to know
when somebody's avoiding or approaching
something so we could heighten that
right that would be a place where you
could probably get a lot of juiciness
emotionally but yeah that's it's it's
definitely a challenge spot i agree
yeah yeah
i wanted to ask about the
shoe fly and logging technologies this
idea of prompt and social interaction
yeah do you think there's any danger of
encouraging uh inauthentic or unnatural
social interactions and expressions
through that where someone you know gets
this prompt to do something and they say
okay i'm going to go do this to like
check a box yeah yeah actually doing
what they may you know naturally or
having this authentic express well i
mean okay so i think that gets to the
age-old argument and games of intrinsic
versus extrinsic motivation
really good game design works with
people's intrinsic motivation
i chose to step into that magic circle
because i'm up for it
should you be able to shut your little
shoe fly up
of course you should like it should
never be a death march to socializing do
you know what i'm saying that's why i
was careful to say no no corporate shoe
fly distribution like it needs to be a
consensual but however people make
frames like think of like folk games
like egg egg and spoon races
it's like people are always making
frames for socialization that help
newcomers jump right in that people with
different capacities can do so we
already do this all the time we're just
not used to thinking of it in
association with technology i think it's
just kind of like a strange
mix of flavors maybe
yes
um okay
hi can you hear me yes
great um i'm kind of actually looking at
social vr
um kind of as a sort of
uh successor to games like facade
it's a video game where you know you're
trying to
deal with the relationship between these
two um you know
lovers of married people named trip and
grace yeah and yeah i think that
including those kinds of
say interactions and you know having
some sort of
person or person in gpt3
to chat with um kind of as an additional
participant would help improve like the
social vr experience
well it's possible that i've been on the
virtual human quest my whole career and
i think we're nowhere near
so a colleague designed that game
michael mathias is one of the designers
of that game and i have to tell you when
i played that game
i got so irritated with tripp and grace
after five minutes that i just left
i was like you are neurotic freaks i
would never have dinner with you i'm
done
so like i kind of have a high bar for
virtual humans so
that's why like i think pets might be
good to aim for or like actually like we
built this um
little little haptic robot thing that's
like a little anxious creature that you
pet to calm down i think there's a lot
of room for like
not exactly anthropomorphic but like
that like being very
measured
in your objectives with the
being that's introduced it could be
fireflies what if you had fireflies in
vr
and what if like when people smiled they
got a little brighter and they like
floated a little higher
i mean i'm just saying like it doesn't
have to be literally another like a
humanoid thing you've got to animate
you've got to have a whole mental model
it's got to keep track of everything it
said to you that's super heavy weight
and i'm not even sure how much you get
from it yeah is that mathias game is
that automatically generated narrative
it's procedural narrative yeah yeah and
i don't i don't know exactly like the
total underlying mechanics but yes that
that it was basically like an example an
exemplar a built example or a procedural
narrative yeah
uh no no it's just like a downloadable
yeah
yeah um i have a hot tick i don't i
don't believe in ddr
okay the reason is because i feel like
there's a high entry barrier to getting
a device itself yeah yeah and i feel
like people who are poorer especially
for low-income countries or
less developed countries you wouldn't
have this opportunity to
to to learn vr that's why i don't
believe in it i get that i get that
however
however
phones
completely jumped landlines and much
faster in developing countries
and things like the quest 2 are like not
that far off from a slightly augmented
phone so i think you're right now
but that might not be true in a few
years you know so but that's fair and
that's a good question to ask of any
technology do we even need it at all and
who is using it who has access to it
absolutely
yeah
yeah
yes um well i'm also really i also
really like ideas of like social
wearables as well as like
like the hardware stuff yeah i'm kind of
concerned about
um developing these because i mean a
very
strong reason why phones and laptops are
so popular is because with one piece of
hardware you run thousands and thousands
of softwares and thousands
of tests yeah and so
i'm kind of concerned about just like
the environmentalism behind this with
um the costs and the materials behind
like getting
these hardware builds um and then you
know like apple comes out with a new
device every sure years like these
hardware will be updated again yeah yeah
yeah
um and i'm just really worried about
like the the proliferation
yeah no i agree i i feel you on that i
mean
most of the things we made are with
little diy processors that can be
repurposed into other things and in fact
we repurpose them when we go on to build
different prototypes so i think you
could
imagine a model in which there is some
kind of standard where there's a little
processor and there's little tools like
kind of like going to a sewing store
right where you're thinking about the
modularity and the longevity but i think
that's a deeper issue in technology
which gets into
kind of the forced obsolescence and the
inability to decompose something
into parts that can be reused and i'm
very sympathetic to that perspective and
i agree i certainly don't want to cause
a proliferation of more and more of this
stuff yeah
like in the future how do
people like distribute their times
between like in the real world and in
like vr environments yeah along with
this ben and beer what type of things
would they do
yeah
i mean so so like one thing i realized
when we all went on zoom is that i've
already been a zoom dweller for quite a
while because i'm an academic and i
collaborate with we need to be a global
community
but yet we shouldn't be traveling in
airplanes so much probably
but we need to not fray
the kind of amazing like rhizomatic
network of humans like part of what
airplanes bought us is like there's so
many people from all over who are here
at stanford like i've worked with people
all over the world like that wasn't true
when i was a young person for most
people
so like i i think part of our thinking
about that has to be like
what does it afford or facilitate that
we want to maintain like as kind of a
human organism
right we've accustomed ourselves so this
kind of like network of communication
involves traveling we need to stop doing
that so i think
vr could be a part of that mix
right and it could be a part of the mix
i think for
conferences have not solved mingling on
zoom okay and zoom is not so great for
subtle aside conversations and kind of
gently broaching a topic it's very
hard-edged
so i think we may find that an immersive
3d environment is just more appropriate
for certain kinds of conversations and
also if we have things like the
fireflies
it might just lighten a tough convert
like you might choose to have a
conversation with a colleague who's
remote be like let's really get into vr
i don't want to do this on zoom
so i think you could see it as part of
an ecosystem of tools
and that's we need to be very thoughtful
about what are the importances of each
how do we design affordances in to sort
of support our humanity if you will
um i just have a question on like um how
like social games
do you feel like
uh because of social games people might
get addicted to social games
and after that they don't know how to
interact outside of yeah um
virtual environments yeah that's the
problem with music i think it really
depends on the social game
a lot of people played among us during
the pandemic a lot of people played
animal crossing those are most like
casual low lightweight startup but just
really charming
really uplifting really kind of just a
bomb to one's soul right but if you're
talking about a persistent hardcore
level up level up level up level up
level up kind of intense play situation
and maybe you're talking about an
adolescent who feels like the world is
really overwhelming
like mastering that stuff is a hell of a
lot more confusing in the real world
than in the game gosh i know when i'm
better because i get these levels yeah i
think someone can get out of whack with
that
i think we have to be wise about that we
have to say okay
what is going on for this young person
that this is so much more compelling to
them it probably has to do with being
empowered and feeling like they know
what the heck's going on and they're of
value so maybe we start there right
obviously yeah i mean i think some
business models now that things have
become services
it is way too enticing for companies to
grab you for as much time as they can
and that's a societal level discussion
right where you may need regulation it's
like nope
you can't you can't design certain
things like we we regulate gambling
machines because we know they tweak
people's brains in certain ways like i
think yeah we've got to have those
conversations yeah well thank you so
much catherine can we give her a big
round